one question you did not get that you
were wishing to get for your talk like
what and what would be the answer to
that. So what's the question you really
wanted to get uh but you didn't get so
and we'll we'll just start or it from
you and go around like that. Yeah.
>> Wow. That's that's a big one. Um so hi
everyone again. Uh I'm a senior lecturer
for strategy and complexity at Regent
University London and I was talking
about urban serendipity because a lot of
my work is on the future of cities. Um a
question that I didn't get
um I think was about okay so how can we
make this happen?
uh really you know is there an appetite
within this audience to perhaps start to
analyze these things more deeply
and I was thinking that maybe we could
start with a bit of a appetizer today
and u since there's quite a few
fantastic ontologists also here um since
you're talking about serendipity and
bibe especially I'd love to see if we
could do a bit of data therapy as we
call
and uh create a ontology a draft
ontology of vibe.
Yeah. So we'll get to that later. That
will be one of our topics and audience
participation. Very welcome. So I'll be
passing on the mic. But let's get to you
Maya next.
>> All right. Well, that sounds really
interesting. I mean we you need to find
another topic like that for the
nontologist
folks. All right. Hi everyone. My name
is Maya Natraan and uh the title of my
talk yesterday was uh combating cyber
crimes in in the financial industry
using graphs. Um just a little bit of uh
uh background on me. Um I'm VP of
product marketing at that dot which is a
streaming graph company. So we combine
streaming data with with graphs. And
then I also uh I'm also the founder of
node to node um a consulting firm that
helps graph companies take their
technology or product to market. What
question would I like? Um oh my gosh
what what did I not get?
What's the thing that excites me most
about graphs?
>> Okay.
>> And what will be the answer or do I have
to answer it right now?
>> Well, we can also keep it for later.
Free fish. Okay.
>> All right. Um, hi, my name is Finbeck.
Um, I gave a presentation yesterday
called It's like Facebook but for
terrorists. And I was speaking about um
sort of how we built an open-source data
stack for making a database of
internationally sanctioned and watch
listed entities. And um the question
that I'm always most scared of the
people asking me is do sanctions work?
Um to which I reply I'm a programmer but
no. Um, and um, the question that I
didn't get asked yesterday that I'd love
to have is like, can I come play and um,
collaborate on the open source part of
the stuff?
>> Can I?
>> Yes, please. We need we need the GPU
power.
>> Uh, Brad Ree with Nvidia in case you
didn't notice with all the swag. Uh, so
my talk was on our graph product called
Kougraph. Um, my my background has been
in graphs for wow 26 years now. uh
building large graph systems. Um and
that really the question that really did
not come up actually came up in
conversations afterwards is you know
we're building this product but what are
we focused on? Um, a lot of people are
building like knowledge graphs and um,
what I would call kind of like small
medium-sized graphs while I'm going
after the very large retail FSI
customers that you know they come to me
and they say I have a trillion edges and
I need to run it in seconds. What can I
do? So, it's kind of a different set of
problem than what a lot of people are
talking about. So it came up in
conversations but not as a direct
question
>> and and something that I picked up from
from your talk that I would ask like all
of us to contribute to is what actually
makes a graph because you made this
point that uh graph database doesn't
necessarily like a noisecraft doesn't
have to be in a graph database. It can
also be in the graph engine. And this is
an idea I've been I'm buying into more
and more as I'm I'm looking at problems
in like just when ontologies change and
things like that, the things that happen
then in organizations. I saw it already
way back in IKEA. I'm seeing it in my
we're we're actually um doing a graph
engine currently in in the company I am
and um it's interesting especially for
the graph algorithm space. So I think it
was Maya talking about graph algorithms.
And Frit you also have graph algorithm
that's kind of a little bit yeah but
that was also what what you're running
and if we do these like graph algorithms
which is actually one way of using the
data graph engine makes more sense right
>> so Maya did a wonderful talk and she had
a slide with the various uh FSI attack
points um and those are the areas that
we're focused on so those algorithms
that were mentioned we do those fast so
that you know when you swipe your credit
card, you'll get a fraud thing within,
you know, a reasonable amount of time
because I'm I'm sure everyone gets, you
know, aggravated when you swipe your
card and you stand there just staring at
the machine and everyone in line is
staring at you saying, "Come on."
>> Okay, Sebastian, over to you.
>> Hey, hello. Good morning. My name is
Sebastian Miller. I'm I'm CTO of YWorks.
We are all focused on visualization. So,
we do graph visualization. We don't do
much of on the business domain side. Um
but we really focus on visualizing the
things. So you give us give us the data
and we try to visualize it. And the
question that I was both like hoping for
to come and also was afraid to answer in
a way was something like well I have
these 10 billion uh nodes in my database
and I want them to see on my screen. So
how do I do this? Then that's a typical
question and and uh the answer I like to
give is well go to Google go to image
search and look for hairball and take
the first image and that's your graph
and because well honestly I don't think
there's any use in trying even trying to
uh visualize these graphs as a whole and
in a way yeah that's that's an answer I
both love to give and hate to give
because obviously I don't really have a
solution but I I I'd like to tell people
that that doesn't make sense what you're
trying to do. You need to take a
different perspective to to get the
right answers from your data.
>> Yeah. and and something that the
thoughts that came to me when I was
listening to your talk is um ultimately
um ontolo we always see ontology as like
there's only one true ontology and as
ontologists we're here to find it and
and it's going to be amazing and
building it for two years and having big
arguments with everyone about the that
one class and so on. Um but the other um
um end of that spectrum is okay let's
try to find this information and then
let's try to find this information I
think these are connected like that or
they could be also connected like this
or this is connected by two hops so now
for this kind of analysis that I want to
do in this other context I'm going to
just connect them directly and that's
what you were also explaining in the
visualization that it's it's an
interpretation which is on top of your
ontology kind kind of um a own shape,
but it's still um logical and it's still
deterministic coming from like a I don't
know I guess the the ultra shape and or
the canonical shape and then you create
that that spin-off and I think that's
that's also really an eyeopener for for
a lot of us that what is an ontology if
we like what is a graph now we're like
what is actually an ontology what makes
it into um into like it needs to be of
this format because for visualization
you might need a different format
depending on the context, right?
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean, most of the
time we we create or or those ontologies
are created with a purpose. So, it's not
the the purpose of creating an ontology
itself, but you you want to do something
with the data. You want to learn
something from the data and then
typically you have multiple use cases,
multiple perspectives that you want to
get on your data and to learn certain
things. you have specific use cases and
for some of these specific use cases
using visualization will help you a lot
and for some it won't but but these
specific use cases typically just use a
subset of your ontologies and so you
need to like find a mapping from from
the the ontology in your data to the one
that you want to see in your
visualization the one that you're
interested right now and not and remove
all the other stuff that you're not
interested
>> thank you Leah over to
Hello, I'm Leah Miller. I'm a lead
ontologist at S&P Global and uh I gave a
talk yesterday about just the very high
level um process for generating a
knowledge graph that wasn't meant to
make a call on any tooling or design
decisions or anything like that, but
just the overall uh process um meant for
developers. So, it was it was more of a
pragmatic approach, I think. Um, and I
actually liked the questions I got to be
honest. Uh, and I think afterward it was
really great to have conversations with
uh, a few people about um, kind of
diving deeper into uh, some of the
challenges they have. So that's kind of
what I was interested in, what people
um, what they are having trouble with in
their general modeling process. So, uh,
yeah,
I don't have a question.
>> Okay. Um, one thing that you and Jeremy
would be nice to hear and Jeremy from
you next, but both of you kind of make
the point about um, like AI readiness
and that in order to really get some use
out of AI now, you really need to
organize your data. So that now there's
like no excuse anymore. It's like the
data people are like your teenager and
it's trying to figure out like I'm going
to get a vacuum cleaner. I'm going to
get this machine and then hopefully
magically my room will be cleaned or I'm
going to get this spraying bottle that
kind of uh you know gives a pleasant
smell in the room but it's still a
teenager's room full of mess and now the
two of you are coming like you finally
need to clean up that room. There's no
excuse. uh you will not be able to
function as a human being for the
teenager or the analogy is the
enterprises are not able to function as
AI capable companies if they don't clean
up their room right yeah Jeremy up to
you yeah
>> yeah I couldn't agree more
um so I'm Jeremy um I founded this
company NASA we are uh aiming at
creating a universal data and AI
platform which means that uh from the
the story that I got uh I'm looking at
it as uh how to support decision-
making. I've been a treasury cash flow
analyst for sea level for a long time uh
in different industries and uh it's
always about how do you distribute the
the cash flow the treasury simulation so
what if this change what if this change
so you need to model all the different
domains strategy marketing sales
operation finance to uh get to this cash
flow simulation and so when I saw AI
coming in um I obviously was interested
into distributing those insights through
a natural language interface like chat
GPT or whatever. And um to do that you
have your good old data engineering but
you need to have an artifact and onto we
figured that ontologies was the way to
actually align the LLMs to the actual
organizational data. So that's what
we're doing. We're trying to crack this
u it's working so far pretty
interestingly with ontologies and that's
why I'm here to share this experience
that we got how far we went. I'm working
with research people. I'm working with
audit and consulting firms as well as
developing this platform. And the the
question that I didn't got is uh how do
you sell that to sea level?
And um the answer is uh you need to
teach them to clean their mess.
>> You need to convince your teenager of a
C level to clean up their
>> CEOs are teenagers.
>> Yeah. Well, teenagers are um they really
like all these Pinterest pictures of a
clean room. So then they go to IKEA and
decorate their room with like nice um
fake plants and
>> the the fake
>> I would say that they believe that what
happens in their mind uh should happen
as fast in their systems and um they
it's really a big big gap um and uh I
mean the aim at the end is to try to get
as close as we can to that because it's
how you know interesting decision can
happen and you can you and basically
accelerate to the the direction that you
want to go to faster. But the but the
the it's it's a function. I think it's
the mass and the acceleration the Newton
kind of stuff where you if you're too
heavy, you're not clean properly, you
you cannot accelerate and go to where
you want to go. So clean your mess and
then start like using tools to
accelerate and to have different
perspectives is like how we approach the
thing. Um many times at EK I explain to
um our stakeholders and subject domain
experts that um that it's it's bit of
the conmari of data and I think with
conmari what works with it is it has a
overall system a bracket system of first
you clean the books and what was it you
you put the books in a pile and then you
take the ones that spark joy or sparkle
joy and um sorry ontologist joke here
But what I want to get to now is for all
of us to collaborate in an doing the
vibe ontology because that's really and
um I want to see like who is team
ontology. We're going to have team
subject matter expert and team ontology.
So who joins team ontology?
I'm your moderator. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You're Robert Veronica. Team ontology.
Everyone's participating also from the
audience. Who's team ontology? Yeah.
>> Ontologies. Yeah. Good. Okay. Cool.
Who's team domain expert? Vibe. You want
to be in domain expert team?
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Led by. Yes.
>> Interesting. I don't know much.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And uh please speak to the
mic. Just remember to
>> I don't know much but I want to know.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, um anyone's heard of
data therapy? I mean every ontologist
does this but Ashley Faith and I we call
it we like to call it data therapy and
it's just a way to work with subject
domain experts. Um and the first
question of data therapy is what are the
things so what are the things of vibe
and all right I let you start but if
anyone else wearing now the subject
matter expert of vibe is please chip in
but let's have a brainstorming what are
the things of vibe okay so perhaps first
let's understand what vibe is so a vibe
is an emotional
uh sense that people intuitively sense
within a space. So you walk into a space
and you have an emotional sense of it.
It could be energetic, it could be
sociable, it could be snobbish, it could
be off-putting, it could be scared,
whatever it is. So what is that in
simultaneously
generated uh and uh intuitively sensed
emotion of a space?
Okay, we have two concepts, emotion and
space. Any subject matter experts that
want to contribute to VIPE? Yes,
Bradley.
>> So, I have a friend that's a disc jockey
and and we've talked about using AI to
help him. And basically, you have a
camera monitoring the crowd and as music
plays, you you monitor how many people
are like tapping or getting into it
versus just wondering. So um you can try
and measure you know the emotional
connection to what's going on based on
actions
>> action or maybe movement. So so a
particular kind of action a movement.
Yep.
>> Is there I'm I'm here like hearing
rhythm as well. Is there a sense of
rhythm? There's some musical elements to
vibe as well. Well, in this particular
case,
>> uh, in this case, but I mean, you can
extend that to, um, I think you were
doing a example of a playground, you
know, are people interacting or just
using it as a shortcut. Um, so if the
movement that you're detecting is in
line with
>> kind of a playful spirit versus just a
you're in my way type thing. Yeah, I
think that we can definitely define
certain patterns of movement within the
space that uh we can use to start
analyzing.
>> But uh could wipe vibe also be a a
personal a subjective feeling that can
actually enact agency on the
environment. So if you have a very
negative vibe, you can change the vibe
of the room or is it always a group
phenomenon?
>> So it is a systemic property. It is
something that doesn't really exist at
the unit level, but it's it's through
emergence exist at the systemic level.
And this is what makes it really tricky
because it's not something that you can
observe at the individual level. But
definitely it is a wave in that sense.
it spreads across the space and and it
can change and I guess the main question
is how can you create a positive
sociable one as opposed to negative one.
>> Um I would ask orit if you can please
speak closer to the mic so we can hear
you because Veronica actually is drawing
here already an ontology which is or
draft of things and it would be
wonderful to get it there but Veronica
needs some support in hearing. So let's
all pay attention to speaking up and
speaking into mics. Okay? And um the mic
is like I'm used to sing into mics. So
actually this is the way you speak to
mics. But but because we have our
technician over here um they are you
know kind of looking a little bit that
we can also don't need to have our lips
touching the mic but do yeah do have it
in front of you.
>> We'll do sorry about that.
great because it it would be lovely or
uh if anyone else wants to draw on paper
while we're doing this that would be
great but uh to summarize what do we
have we have a feeling we have a space
we have the movement
um was there something about the
movement still like I was suggesting
rhythm but there was also like the
something about the frequency of the or
something like that right
>> I guess you could say the um
group moving in unison versus just
individuals
um not moving at all.
So that like from an ontolo like okay
ontologist come to the rescue what how
would we model even using BFO what would
be a top class for something where
things are happening at the same time or
there's a like a group um yeah joining
yeah
>> process
>> pro
this we're very very top top
>> yeah very top there's also observations
that you start with an observation and
that can be the beginning of some sort
of a flywheel. I'm always thinking about
how things are connected together.
There's many different ones. So maybe an
observation lead to describing a little
bit more uh what are the the things that
are observed.
Yeah, sorry I just picked up on the
emergence
stuff because if this is an emergent
phenomena then there must be a carrier
of the vibe that can emit or uh um uh
receive uh signals leading to
decline or increasing uh vibe. Would
that be fair? And then it it would be
interesting to investigate for for me if
this is indeed encodings we are talking
about I mean representations of
something or we if we can narrow down on
the thing itself
>> that's really fascinating because
obviously there are signals right
because otherwise it wouldn't spread
through the space so part of it might be
observational so if I see certain rhythm
of movement of people or if I see small
groups clustering and declustering. So
you have a flexibility of interactions
within that space. So that might be some
kind of signals. Um but it might also be
through
my interaction. So certain conversations
uh certain small interactions with
people. And the more you have it, the
acceleration of the vibe spreads because
if you think about it, if you walk into
a conference or a room and and it's all
really buzzing, you get that sense,
right? And you feel much more
comfortable uh to then interact with
people. So, how would you define that
buzz?
Yeah, I was going to say exactly the
same thing that the definition is part
of the description which comes after the
experience. So what you're observing in
the moment is something that is an
emergent property. It's very very hard
to break that down in the moment of
where did this come from? But what you
could do is if you analyze all the
descriptions that people say afterwards,
well what are the patterns we see in
those descriptions and then what do we
observe what's happening in the moment?
So descriptions after the event seem
really important.
I think the descriptions that would be
like reviews and things like that. We're
talking about signals that you put into
social media that you could pick up
later, somebody writing a story. But I'm
thinking here also like just kind of
picking up on that how do we observe
why? How do we observe emotions as
humans like cognitively? I think there's
elements of cognition here as well and
there's we already mentioned movement.
We're really great at sensing movement.
Somebody's like this, like that, or if
somebody's fluid and and so on. So,
that's one. Facial expressions. We
actually have neurons in our brains that
are primed for fa facial expressions.
That's why you see Jesus in toast
because you have these like certain you
have a bit of a sensitivity for picking
that uh stuff up. So, so I was thinking
that maybe we need in order to create an
ontology for vibe, we need to understand
human cognition as well. We need to have
a map for that. Anyone's worked in that
space? Any domain experts in the room?
>> Yeah, kind of. Or other comment.
I'm by no means a domain expert but um
we're discussing a lot um uh perhaps the
55% of uh Albert Marabian's theory of 7
3855 which is we communicate uh 7%
through words uh 38% through um the tone
and 55% through uh the way people move
or facial expressions things like this
um so I kind of I want to talk a bit
about the 38% which is not me but
somebody else in the domain field could
talk about uh the 38% how we use tone to
communicate and that's something that
can be picked up on uh I don't know how
how it be measured but
so tone is music and when a m I I have
this because I have a a degree in music
as well did musiccology um for some time
yeah and um
but I I Think like if if um dance is the
poetry of movement then music is the
poetry of communication because sound
originally if you think about birds came
for communication reasons like danger
food making whatever like pairing up and
so on and um and so maybe there is that
element of self we can take now movement
as one concept in our ontology ology and
the other concept would definitely be
sound. And I think at this point we
maybe have a first version of our
ontology. We have our elements. We have
our classes. We already had some
relationships as well. I was picking up
some object properties here in terms of
um emotion being connected to a space or
or something like that. Yeah. And
anything else? Anyone else picking up
some connections between these things?
Yeah. Sorry.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry, you you sent me off a
line of thoughts because um if we look
at bees, uh a bee doesn't have a brain
in from from which it can have a map of
the world. So, it's it it cannot really
have a language. Still a a a flock of
bees. It's not called a flock in
English, is it? Uh, many bees can have
vibe.
>> Swarm.
>> A swarm. There we go. Oh, yeah. Swarm
intelligence. There we go. Uh, they they
can have a vibe of being agitated, which
we can perceive, but the bees themselves
also know that they're agitated by uh
exchanging pherommones. Uh, and then we
we can as human recognize that I
shouldn't approach the beast because I'm
going to get stung. Uh but that that's a
right to even in a in a in a more uh
simplistic system with a type of
representation we would have a very hard
uh time putting into an an ontology I
would
suppose.
>> Yeah. All right. Any studies on furbones
for vibe
>> definitely swarm is a really interesting
one. Uh even if you think about the
difference between a grasshopper and
locust which is actually the same
creature but when you have a certain
density in the population. So the
grasshopper is really chilled and really
laidback and you know really um and then
when you have a certain density in the
population something chemically changes
in that organism and they become locust.
They grow much bigger suddenly.
um and they are suddenly able to fly and
you know eat and destroy loads and loads
of fields. So it is those thresholds I
think that
so I don't know how would you define
thresholds in that regard just to make
it a bit more complicated.
>> Yeah, I'd love to throw that to any of
the ontologists in the room. How do you
work with thresholds?
um at at currently the ontology I'm
building I'm looking that looking at
that as a future state.
So so you have like your current state
and there's a future state and then they
have a connection. So I'm setting a
number for the future state and um I'm
setting another object for the current
state and it has a time and date and so
on. Go ahead.
>> Yeah, you triggered me with the BFO
syncing. It's a disposition uh of future
states. So we talked about it. It's a
disposition and uh there is participants
in those disposition that will change
the vibe. So there's like a process with
participants that realize that there is
a disposition uh and current roles of
those participants that are like putting
things together. That's how the top
level uh nodes of this BFO top level
ontology works. And uh it helps like
breaking down because it's it's very
abstract in a way but it helps putting
things into
uh some sort of an order. So disposition
is would be like uh
>> yeah and disposition. So just to explain
what we mean when we say BFO
um basic formal ontology
it is actually just really logical. It's
very abstract. It's kind of touching
upon the physics of things. So something
that can materialize or something that
is it cannot materialize immaterial but
is still existing only in one point of
time or existing over time unchangeable.
And it's it's really interesting when
you get to it. It's very philosophical
and um kind of like research in general.
We always put things into a mold. So I
think we can find these um things also
there the the behavior of things
>> and it it emerged from the the genome
project that was mapping the the DNA. Um
so it's quite interesting to see how
they came with this abstraction of um of
of things um through the the BFO stuff.
It's right now one of the most used uh
in the biomedical domain. Yeah,
>> let's do a little bit of attention
because I also wanted to touch upon like
we have we have some idea of we have a
first version of the ontology maybe
drawing some drawing
>> some arrows some balls and lines and um
let's discuss a little bit also Leah I
think you were saying that well I don't
really need that top top highlevel
philosophy thing I need something for
the enterprise which usually I will call
a middle layer ontology, middle
ontology. I I had I discovered the same
thing at IKEA. I had numerous
conversations with Barry Smith, one of
the authors of BFO, uh on how I would
use BFO with IKEA. And the only thing
that we practically really needed was a
middle level one first. That's what we
needed because we didn't really need to
be interoperable with the world or
interoperable across verticals. Leah,
would you want to elaborate on your
experience there?
>> Yeah. Um Yeah. So I think um so in this
context, just sticking with the vibe um
um example, I I think uh is this better?
Sorry, I'm gonna have to be a little
closer. Um I think what what's coming I
know we have a lot of high level ideas
of of how to to look at it but maybe we
could look at uh what data points we'd
be getting. So from from the room uh uh
we could start to have um uh how many
people in the room kind of data point
that would go into our analysis. Uh the
shape of if it's a conference setting so
maybe we'd have different contexts. So
we'd have a content uh context filter.
So conference would be a value. And then
we'd have uh a shape of um tables.
There's some uh studies around that. If
it's a round table versus if it's in
kind of a school desk kind of by twos,
you're going to have a different
dynamic. So we could kind of get into uh
further analysis knowing what the actual
data points of the space are. um the
kind of music playing. We could create
data around that and how that uh so
actually tracking those data points,
putting that into the analysis, having
that link up to roll up to our ontology
concepts at the sorry at the mid um uh
so I would I would see it from that
perspective I think is really helpful to
kind of ground it. And then um and I
also wanted to get into this you know uh
the the BFO example and and having an
upper level. I think I would be
interested in talking about uh using
that to um break down um the silos that
could be created by you know I'm we're
creating a vibe ontology here but there
are the the other team in our org is
also creating one and it's slightly
different and how do we how do we group
that together so that's that's where
that I that core ontology idea or that
top level is going to come in and be
helpful. So, um, but you need both. I I
think you need both.
>> Okay. Wow. That was like a treasure
trove of ideas. I love how we we first
went into like from data therapy of like
really looking at high level and then
Leah's coming in of well look at the
data like what kind of data do we have?
what's actually possible for us to then
work on which is the more practical
bottom up approach and um or pract
grounded in data and and what's
interesting here is or I would love to
hear what you think about like slightly
thing like fields that are looking at
slightly similar things
uh maybe outside of the urban
development like surely some like
musical analysis or
I don't know interior design,
architecture, like which which
industries or which fields
are looking at slightly similar things
and do they already have an ontology we
could look at? Yeah. So I think um
perhaps another way to look at it is
from an economics perspective and other
fields that are looking at this even
let's just make it simple from a retail
perspective right so if you think about
we all shop online right now so uh shops
want us to come in more for the
experience and and to get a sense of
their brand because this is where they
can communicate with us. So shops are
becoming uh a channel of communication
rather than a point of sale. Uh so in
that sense they are trying to push the
people that come into the shop towards a
certain uh feeling a certain narrative a
certain identity. So I think that is
slightly similar. Uh but generally when
you look at everything around nudge
theory and just getting people to change
behaviors again it is all about
emerging processes um that can be
datadriven but we don't control what
people actually do. So how do we nudge
them down certain um certain directions
behaviors uh etc. So, so you see those
same things happening in other places
and and I think that what you raised is
is the real uh difficulty here because
you have multiple sources of data. Um
and you have human behavior and human
psychology. Uh so there are certain
patterns that we know we can expect
because you know how people relate to
music, how think about you know uh films
and and the music that really sets the
scene. Is it a comedy or a horror film?
Um, so these things are there, but then
how do you translate that into data and
into new solutions without making it too
creepy or we do we have to make it super
creepy? I don't know.
>> Yeah. Building from the horror film, I
just recognized that one distinguishing
feature of vibe in a room for a human
being would be eye contact. So if you
enter a room and there's a really good
atmosphere if they suddenly all stare at
you, it would sort of kill the the vibe.
So So working from that, you you can
enter a lot of sort of coupre movie
scenarios where eye contact one one
person is looking at you in a room but
everyone else is is having fun. Eye
contact suddenly becomes quite
determining for your uh exposure to the
vibe.
Okay. So, I'm wondering just for
information, by the way, we have 45
minutes here still. Um, you can request
a a break if you want. Um, but I think
we're are we happy to keep going.
>> I have a question actually just to carry
on in terms of the data. What do you do
when it's a process? So it's not just
what is the data currently in the room
like for example you were talking about
how the place is set and the number of
people but it is constantly shifting
this is a wave. So initially there'll be
like five people and there won't be five
and you know more people will come in
and it might be really friendly or
suddenly there'll be a staring match and
it won't be friendly anymore. How do you
deal with data and time?
Well, you think you want to go start?
>> This one working. Okay. Uh Dexter from G
Research did a great talk yesterday on
adding well yeah yesterday on adding
time um and how you should capture all
these timestamps and you can have like a
a whole time graph that links into your
other graph. So this way you can say hey
at this point in time what was going on?
>> Yeah exactly. So if you model with
thresholds you would then observe them.
you make each point an observable thing
and when it kind of goes over that's a
that triggers then something else and
>> and then there's also great talks on uh
causality which you you can consider is
you know here's one state here's the
other state what was uh you know how was
there a transition
>> time is really hard uh to express in
knowledge graphs because knowledge graph
is always just expressing attributes
So then you do need to add the timestamp
information and maybe look at something
like there's a state and then there's an
event and that changed that state and so
it's like this thing of Carl shot a lion
first the lion is alive and then the
lion is dead and and do you have now in
your knowledge graph lion is alive and
dead as data points or like what's
happening and how do you know that now
it's not alive anymore it was alive
before that that's um because it's
knowledge graph is not like a function.
It's just a data structure really in the
end. It just sits there. It doesn't do
anything. You need to do something with
it. And so when we design ontologies and
knowledge graphs, we design we need to
design for like a window of of of things
and and then kind of take it from there.
It's I' I've been putting there thinking
about it. if anyone wants to add to that
or but one thing I I really wanted to to
get here we seeing a little bit of like
hopefully this is a simulation of how
ontologists work and u what kind of
questions we do or like the detective
work we'll be doing with you to discover
this new field of why we do know it but
we don't know all the in-depth research
so we are trying to understand it and
one thing that we said yesterday that we
really want to discuss here is what are
good interview questions for an
ontologist.
So if you you're like okay I want this
this this seems reason like maybe
already you want to hire an ontologist
to work with you. So what would be if
you don't come from the field what would
be good questions for an ontologist and
I'd love to hear now everyone chip in a
little bit to to this because I think
Maya you you've maybe um have gone that
so please what do you think what would
be good interview questions for an
ontologist
>> um close to
>> yeah yeah thank you
>> sorry to throw it on you what is what is
the function of this ontology going to
be
um you know in in in terms of how does
it help with the overall uh in
determining vibe for example in this
case.
>> So that will be a question for the on to
hire someone or
>> well you know is that the question that
did we want to hire? So, so the thing is
you want to um you're putting an
advertisement on LinkedIn saying I'm
hiring an ontologist.
Um how do you assess how good of an
ontologist is? What's a good interview
question for your ontologist? If you
want to have a little bit more time to
think that's fine. Yeah. Yeah. Anyone
else want to maybe Leah or Yeah, the I
think Yeah, let's try it.
>> I can give my answer that I gave
yesterday. Um uh so uh I said that uh
you can ask um a something from your
domain modeling question and ask them
how they would handle it. Uh and then I
had a a nice uh conversation with uh
Peter just after and he thought it
should be uh the opposite something that
they know very well how they would model
it. So, because that can be, you know,
a, you know, kind of a a tricky question
if they're not familiar with your
domain, it could put them on the spot.
Or you could have a third option where
it's a very uh generic
um uh topic like animals or something
that you both the interviewer and
interviewe would know about and then you
would go into something kind of generic
and just walk through it. uh and make it
I think it's important to um uh keep in
mind that uh we've all worked on
different things and different um
different parts of uh a knowledge engine
or you know different kinds of
ontologies or different domains or maybe
some are more familiar with uh with time
and and others aren't uh so um or
working with RDF or label property
graphs or whatever it is so it's
important to get the I think how the
person is thinking about things more so
than being uh than always testing on
something very very specific this very
specific property in in RDF unless
you're testing specifically for that uh
to more get the uh try and gauge the how
the the person thinks and if they can
explain it I think is the
>> yeah how to think and if explain if you
want to yeah
>> I just have to mention this because it's
incredibly ironic. I'm unlikely to hire
any ontologists in the short run. But
like one thing that I spend actually a
lot of time thinking about when I hire
people is like the vibes. Like
I'm trying to kind of predict how is
having them in every meeting that we are
as an organization going forward going
to change sort of the mood in the room,
right? Are they going to make it more
serious? Are they going to make it um
more uh
more
expert driven? Are they going to make it
silly? Are they going to make it fun?
Right? Like, and I think that's like a
to me like it's something that I talk to
my partner about before I hire anyone.
It's like what vibes are they giving me?
Um, and I don't know whether that's
illegal under the law, but like it's
like really strong factor.
>> I I love that. Another thing is um and
the question I ask is how do you work
with non-technical people?
because this is not only a technology
job. This is about working with people,
working with an organization.
Um, yeah, I don't know. How good are you
with teenagers?
Yeah, that I don't have a teenager
actually. Well, yeah. Well, anyway, but
um
and then I I go I look at Veronica.
She's in my over panel and she's an
ontologist, fellow ontologist. Bernick
is like colorful pencils and paper and
then we draw and and that is a really
nice way of that's really non-technical.
Everybody loves mind mapping. It taps
into something. So that will also be a
good question and maybe or you can get a
nice picture here. Sorry, I'm kind of
putting a spot, but a good picture of
like how ontologies work with like,
okay, what's the data and how would you
think about it and what is it? And and
that kind of question of making you feel
comfortable and heard hopefully as well.
I think that's really important. Um, you
have a question.
>> Sorry, it was about the how to what
question you would ask an ontologist. So
working from the VIPE scenario, I've now
nailed it down to okay, it's just
recognition of predatorial behavior
because if we if we don't think they're
not going to eat me, I'm going to be
okay. So if we work from that, the most
important thing you could ask antologist
is to how to bridge a human ontology
with a nonhuman because as we and I
think it's the most important question
in the world because as we keep adding
abstractions to our ontology, we're now
moving into vector space. We're moving
into things that we cannot readily
perceive by neither our focused viewing
system or peripheral vision. We're
moving into something we have a hard
time
grasping. So, how can we bridge that?
How can we bridge that gap?
>> That's really interesting.
Are we talking about safe spaces now? Is
this But there there is a sense of being
accepted and
is is vibe actually something very
instinct. Is is white maybe something
that was a matter of I'm going to be I'm
going to be able to eat here. I'm going
to be able to find a mate here. I'm
going to be able to be safe from
predators here. What do you think?
>> Uh yes because we are social creatures.
So this goes back to us as a network. So
I think that initially it is about is
this a dangerous space? And the second
element of the vibe is okay who can I
collaborate with who will go hunting
with me all right who will share the
spoils uh so understanding who we can
collaborate with and then how we connect
with them right so they will collaborate
with us and I think that all of this is
in our subconscious from an evolutionary
perspective so it's really interesting
how it comes out in different settings
whether it's when hiring people and
thinking about what happens in your
company meetings or whether it is within
our wider region.
>> I I have this thought that's nagging in
my mind all the time, this picture in my
head and I'm I wanted to throw it here.
You know how
bus stops or bus terminals
um that are a bit can be dodgy at night,
their solution is to play classical
music to go get all the riff ruff out or
um I've worked a lot in like doing an
audience outreach for classical music
and we always have this problem of
people don't want to come to the opera
because everybody dresses fancy and they
don't know what to wear.
What's that about? What are those two
things about? Why is classical music or
the vibe around classical the scene
around classical music so off-putting?
Um, it's because it it, you know, it
seems more elitist than anything else.
Um, you know, it's it's not not every
common person thinks about classical
music. It it seems at least Okay, I'm
going to I'm going to differentiate
between Eastern and Western classical.
>> Yes.
>> Eastern classical, it is those who are
highly educated. They're the ones who
actually learn classical music and and
you know, they they they have concerts
and everything else. It's not a common
man's uh type of music. And that's why
you see I mean, you know, the common
man's music, reggae and all of those
things that that's what everyone
everyone likes to do and everyone goes
towards, right? and and and I I'm
assuming it's pretty similar in in the
western culture as well. It's an elitist
thing and that's why maybe putting it in
bust terminals makes sense to me because
you know it it just it's very
offputting, right? Um and so that
>> and why why is it elitist? Is it the
skills or
>> I think it's skills. I think it's skills
and knowledge to to actually, you know,
be able to uh play that instrument or
sing in in in that particular way. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I think it's encoded, right? It's
like encoded and you need to invest some
of your leisure time into learning how
to read the codes of like how that piece
was composed and what it means to have
like several movements and what the
hell. Um and um as you can see I haven't
invested that time and like I think kind
of you're signaling by that that you've
had enough leisure time to learn the
codes right
>> yes and I think that we can look at that
again in terms of variables it is about
how many rules are in the space so how
many rules people feel that they need to
conform to so I think that when you talk
about these kind of of situations
there's more knowledge And there are
more rules that everyone seems to comply
with whether how they dress or how they
look at each other and whatever they
talk about and therefore it is a higher
threshold for people to reach. Um so you
could either create a vibe that is more
off or you can think about how you
deconstruct it.
Well, I was going going to make a
comment about symbolism, but I have a
feeling that all that I've said, all
that I was going to say is is somehow
isomeorphic with what you've just said.
Um, so I don't think I'm adding
anything. But I think with the discourse
that we're having now, you have to think
of symbols and representations. So what
does something what does something
whether it's a location or an event or a
logo of a company or a piece of music,
what does it represent to a person? So a
piece of music is not in itself
repellent at at all. It's it is the
relationship between that piece of music
and people. So classical music have it
is a symbol of something. It has become
a symbol of something and in a different
culture it might be a totally different
symbol as a brand can change its its
symbolism um among people.
And so now I think we're reached a a
second layer in our ontology because
we're now looking it's not only about
like the the these kind of datadriven
things of the modalities of sound. I
think ferommones could also be a smell.
I'm thinking about how shops attract
people with certain smells and it makes
it feel very very hot very like high
vibes and you would say oh high vibes
and things like that. But now we're
getting to like our interpretation
of those signals and or of something of
symbols and their meaning.
ontology and knowledge graphs. Um
another term for it is symbolic AI
because also with ontology we are
imposing an always an opinion and uh
point of view and we're treating these
these concepts as symbols uh to which we
encode the meaning in computer
understandable format or at computer
well let's say computable format and um
so so this is this is really interesting
there's a there's a sense of like maybe
history and meaning and culture because
the this whole like it takes time to
learn it. It's hard to learn it and um
then you show you have leisure and you
have you can afford to take this time.
Um yeah, let's just look at the time. We
still have half an hour. I'm wondering
like where we want to take this to now
like any kind of conclusions or um
pictures we want to look at. I mean
there was one more topic that I did pick
up and let's see if we're still going to
um be in the vibe space with that one as
well. Just where is it? There we go. uh
one thing
which is bit bit different but I don't
know it might be a good seed to plant
here as well is
there's something about about the
current AI development and LLMs and then
vector graphs and I now I can't remember
who was actually making this point but
um an LLM is always giving you an
answer. This was the problem that we
recognized like a year ago when this
thing was um mainstream that it's always
giving an answer. It's and it's it could
be lying as well. It could be
hallucinating or whatever. And back then
I was like, well, that just sounds like
a young person who's really well
educated or who who comes from a good
family and knows how to talk eloquently
but actually doesn't have the experience
and the knowledge. So, it's like, you
know, a young snob is like that. they
can always struck strike up a
conversation about anything and and it's
very eloquent. It sounds really good but
then you think about it later like they
actually was that right and and so LLMs
can always have an answer and um then
when we think about um vector databases
um they they don't really they can like
they can have a fuzzy answer. So
somewhere in that direction but
knowledge graphs either know or don't
know. So and there's element was it in
your talk? Yes. So it was an element of
of wisdom is also saying no saying what
you don't know. And now we're looking at
with hybrid AI systems we're looking at
building something where we can say oh I
don't know this fact. So I'm going to
try to theorize on it with my vector
database and if all fails I'm just going
to give some answer if I really need to
or we need to be designing systems that
can that know what they know and then if
they don't know they say well I assuming
it could be this. Do you want to Jeremy
maybe expand on that?
>> Yeah.
Uh the main thing uh you need to do when
you work with decision makers is be
clear on the fact that you don't know if
you don't know. So I've been smashed in
the face many times for that regard. Uh
it's I think so it's very important if
you want to simulate like some sort of
interaction between a human and a tool
or someone that is giving back an answer
to say I don't know let me check it out.
I'll come back to you later or I have
this other source of information that's
not going to be 99% accurate. That's
going to be 8% accurate. But you're
going to have some sort of similarity or
some stuff you can wrap your head
around. And if you if we really don't
have anything, then let me come back to
you. Let me work on this fact and come
back to you with an answer. And so this
this process of I said yesterday green
orange red kind of u mindset where the
knowledge graph will tell you I know for
a fact this is it and or I don't know if
I don't know I go to the other layer and
say maybe the similarity is there. If I
really don't have any any answer then
it's going to be triggering for our case
an issue in the backlog of the d the
data team or the knowledge team so that
this is created for next time and update
the graph and then tomorrow when you
come back you have an answer and I'm
really really focusing hard with my team
on this cracking this flag this this
motion this feedback loop so that it
doesn't take you three weeks to come
back with an answer to someone that ask
you a question but less that's the
obsession that we we have basically so
that's that's my take
>> any any thoughts on that yeah
so what don't we know about vibe
>> then
I guess it's a process and it is about
whether we can actually
define it in a clearer way can we
actually
identify. This is why I'm really
interested in in what you said with
working with the DJ, like where do you
start and how do you expand on that by
adding more data streams and
understanding?
Most of our conversations were just
sitting around over beers talking about
what we could do. So, we never really
implemented anything. But yeah, it's
there's a lot with AI that can detect um
and group things together, but
understanding why that was grouped
together and the meaning behind it is
still kind of fuzzy.
So there's a final exercise in data
therapy that we could now endeavor to
with the last remaining 20 minutes or so
and that is that of competency
questions.
Anyone know competency questions?
Hands up. I know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Let me define
competency question. Close your eyes.
Everyone close their eyes and take a
deep breath in
and deep breath out.
Repeat it second time
and out. And third time. Final one. In
and out. Now keep your eyes closed.
Imagine
that the perfect engine for vibe is
there. You walk up a mountain and you go
and meet the vibe vixen and you're like,
"Hi, Vibe Vixen.
I want to know you. You know everything
about Vibe. You are the creator of Vibe.
You are the origin and source of Vibe.
Now, please answer my question."
Okay.
And Orit, what is your question?
Vipix knows everything about VIP. What
would you ask her?
How do you create it?
So the operational side, I I I get it.
It's understood. But now what can you
intervene
within our environment to actually
change it?
>> VIP vixen answers back dear one please.
Um
what do you want to create?
So I want to create a socialable vibe
where people feel really comfortable
interacting with other people and
strangers and okay striking up
conversations and collaborations for
example. So vipixon is so really or it
what are you asking me? What you the
question you're asking me is how can I
create a comfortable vibe and maintain a
comfortable vibe. That's competency
question number one. It's um at the
appropriate level of things. It's it's
you're already defining something like
comfortable. That comfortable is
something you want to reach. So that's
some that's probably one of our symbols
one of our instances in the in the uh
VIP knowledge graph. And then how can I
create it? So something about like
creating it, bringing it it over the
threshold I guess as we were aligning.
So that's how you would then start
analyzing this question all the way down
to it being an actual database query in
in that format. So that's the first
competency question. Okay, let's close
our eyes. Imagine Vipixen. What color is
Vip Vixon's hair, by the way?
Red.
And she has a a fox fuia blouse and
brown trousers.
Okay. Bye, Bixon. Um, now she's smiling
at you and um open for another question.
Um, what would you ask by Pixon?
Anyone?
Um, I would ask
how can I
how can I um
spread a good w vibe in my everyday
actions?
How could I like be in a situation then
actually access a vibe like, oh, it's a
bit gloomy here. I want to make it
happy. Like, how can I actually as one
person
change the vibe to
calmer? Maybe I want to calm everyone
down. Okay. How could I How could I um
no relax? How could I make a with my own
actions make a situation more relaxed to
create a relaxed vibe? Yeah.
Um I would also ask is vibe continuous
or discrete?
So is it can it can it is is it
fundamentally something that can be put
in buckets or is it always a spectrum of
something
and at this point vixen we say I I just
know about vibe. I'm not here to analyze
vibe. I'm not an ontologist. So you're
still Robert in this like ontologist way
of how could I access vibe. So why do
you want to know this question? What's
why are you asking whether vibe is
continent or to something discrete
>> question
to to understand
what it is
to understand uh how it can be modeled,
how it can be influenced, how it can be
detected. all of those things to
well I I don't I want to model it
>> but maybe like how can I see vibe?
How can I recognize vibe?
Could that be a question?
>> Once I've got one going, how do what do
I need to protect it from? Right? Like
what do the adversaries of the cyber
Oh my goodness. Yeah. Well, so I'm I've
just um it's a it's like I've just
stumbled into a good vibe. How can I
protect good vibe? How can I Because in
that's what you're thinking about in
your interview, right? I have a good
vibe going. I have a good team. Is this
person going to disrupt it, mess it up?
And and Yeah. Yeah. How can I protect my
good vibe? And so Yep.
Yes, just to follow up on the continuous
discreet, I think this is a good example
uh from the kind of data modeling
process of the competency question
having having an impact on how you
model. So uh if we we know that people
are going to ask uh you know what was
the um the the the time series of that
event and the vibe uh we'd we'd say we
didn't model the the time element. we
made a call that it was either it hit a
threshold that it was a positive vibe or
negative vibe overall. Uh so it's just a
vibe per event in our model. So we
wouldn't be able to answer competency
questions around can you give me uh the
start and and how it evolved. Uh we
would only be be able to give uh an
overall um final value for the the vibe.
So that's a good if I know people are
going to ask about that, I'm going to
get right on this kind of time series
element to the event and the vibe. If
it's not important, I'm gonna just have
a single value for that.
And also it it's super important that
these competency questions are actually
defined by the domain experts having
this need to do something with the
information. So we've we've we've kind
of gone through all these different um
um ways of working with ontology. One is
um the the the what are the things the
the theoretical
theoretical thing of what what is this
and the other one is the datadriven one.
What is the data actually saying? What
are the data points that I need to model
for? But the third one with competency
questions are why it's for me it's a
favorite uh for sure to work with domain
experts is that it just says don't worry
about the technology we'll figure it out
later I need to know what you actually
want to do with this information what do
you do want to do with this information
and Robert your concern as an ontologist
is I want to model the information so
I'm going to ask questions about how
could I model it but VIP vixen is more
like I'm I'm just like, you know, vibing
with it. I'm I'm like, what do you want
to do? I I want to pick it up. I want to
pick it up and make it bigger. Vixen,
how do I make a good mood even bigger
and spread across not just this block,
but like the entire neighborhood? Uh or
Vixen, how could I have this every
Friday when people return from the work
and are getting I get a good start to
the weekend and and these because these
are the things. And so like the
recommendation is to to really not think
about the technology but think what you
want to do with it and then the
technology will follow because then you
know you're doing the right technology
and this is like basically product
management stuff right yeah um any
pointers on Yeah.
Um I find it difficult somehow to make
this um those um person who want to use
the graph answer the question what do
you want to do with the data because
they want to do everything they're like
oh I want this I want so it's going
crazy sometimes
um what I've been finding interesting is
where do you want to go what's the state
in which you want to be and then this is
more easy for a person to answer like
because it's more uh for a business
business people is like oh I want to be
leading my
market I want to have 20% margin and
that's helping to drive all the other
stuff that they want to that needs to be
done. So it's uh it's the same question
but instead of what do you want to do is
just what do you want and uh and it's
helping a lot I mean to what we do uh to
help uh you know break down the well
everything I have this data I want to do
everything with it uh which is somehow
very hard to to catch
>> well I'm feeling the vibe is getting M
we're kind of like done and maybe tired
and I'm out of topics. You're out of
questions. Everybody's out of comments
or not like closing remarks, closing
thoughts about um
y
sorry changing the topic slightly to
visualization.
So visual discovery is is very powerful.
You know people are great at finding
patterns. How do you ensure that you're
not artificially influencing somebody
towards something? Because by color
choice, node size, edge size, you can
say, "Oh, there's the problem right
there." And it's like, "No, don't look
at that one. Look at this one." That
comes up a lot in terrorist networks
where they try to hide themselves. And
if you color code something wrong,
people jump to that conclusion. And yes,
I have created charts that artificially
influence managers to pick things my
way, but that's a different topic.
>> Yeah, that's a good question. The good
question is I don't do this. I don't
color the one. So, um um luckily I don't
decide about this. Um uh but um that's
basically also the topic that we just
had and it's kind of like overarching uh
all the discussion that um we need to
watch the the purpose what are we trying
to do with it? So so why are we doing
this? So what is it that we want to get
answers for? So and um uh in a way uh
that's the same with with v
visualization. So why are you looking at
your graph? what do you want to know?
And only if you have the right
questions, you can get the right
answers. So don't always just focus on
the data and then think about what
questions you might want to ask, but
start with the questions. Start with
what you want to know. And um and then
of course, yeah, it's it's your duty as
the one who creates the questions or
tries to um creates a template for the
answers. Well, to make this in a way
that it's hopefully unbiased because
yeah, because in a way once we create a
topology or when we create a an ontology
or when we create a visualization,
typically we we create templates for for
the way that we want to describe the
facts to someone else. And that well
that's that's a that's a difficult task
because as you said this can be very
very well biased by our choices.
Anything else?
I love how we pivoted to visualization.
That's really nice. Yeah.
>> Um I'm not quite sure if I'm staying on
topic with this, but it's it's uh
I was thinking how sort of opinionated
data can be or or how maybe you could
have an ontology that's opinionated or
nonopinated and how things are. you
know, you could say I like someone, but
maybe it should be I've had
communication with someone in the past
and it's been positive communication or
whatever. And um possibly how you can
twist ontologies to have certain
outcomes. And I guess the same applies
for data v visualization.
>> Yeah. I mean, anything can be modeled
most of the time. Well, um,
any further topics or questions, last
remarks,
then final question. We're going to
start here and go all the way back down.
Is there something new that you learned
today and also yesterday? And think
about the track now specifically. I mean
we also had other talks and so on but
did you learn something new um in the
track and in this discussion today I can
actually start um I'm taking home uh a
stronger sense of a graph doesn't really
need to be in a in a database it can
also be in an engine it's really the
connectedness of things that I need to
drive for in which physical format that
is that's a a secondary very point
>> I follow that like I also agree that um
the database itself it does doesn't
really
uh make the point of the whole thing.
So, um what I um what I've learned is um
that we are into a unique uh time. Uh
I'm looking forward to see where we
stand in a year when we do this again. I
hope uh because it's uh very very
dynamic and there is a lot of stuff
happening. So
more than just what I've learned, I'm
feeling super grateful of like meeting
all those people here, of having this
kind of event here and um and I'm I'm
really looking forward for what what
going to be next year about
>> um yeah, same here. I I just to touch on
that that um or I feel like we're all uh
in very much experimental mode uh
research mode right now and I'm excited
for next year. Um I think uh specific to
the um the interaction around the data
modeling uh bits and how we uh how we
view u ontology differently. That's not
a new thing. But I I think uh I'm
learning from the uh discussion this
this really important idea for
enterprise data, this core ontology, how
we're going to do that and what um
ontology levels or layers we need uh to
accomplish that. And um uh so I think
that discussion um is just going to
continue. But I think that's something
that would be really worthwhile to
formalize a little more uh in with the
the the people here and um provide a a
solution for um enterprise uh those use
cases I think would be um really great.
>> Yeah, thank you. Um, honestly, I I
didn't learn too many big new things.
So, so, but it was astounding to me how
many small things I I learned and that
and seeing that that everything is still
in motion, that we're still uh we're
still getting there. It's still an
active uh topic. All these topics are
super active and interesting. And um of
course, I learned new people, but uh not
those big things, but the many small
things. and and there's certain topics
that uh reappear in different um uh in
different perspective again again and
again and that's yeah I I again I'd say
I'm super excited to see what's coming
and uh hope to be back again next year
all the great answers are used up
already so I come from a very
traditional math graph theory background
where you know a graph is just a node in
a line with no meaning to it. Um, and
I've always been kind of slowly evolving
of what more can I add to it. And you
know, it's great to talk about processes
and and rethink things not in a math
perspective, but more on a ontological,
you know, worldview of what this means.
What I'm learning is that we're all kind
of data space cadets here. I feel we're
like the people in organizations that
get the freedom to really think about
data in a more abstract way than you
know the people who have to make a new
button appear in the internet and the
people who have to implement a new a new
regulation from the tax code and all
that right and I feel like flying high
is fun. Um I think kind of there is a
now pretty good history in the in the in
in in kind of computing of the high-f
flyers getting over overtaken by the b
bottom movers right that the people who
solve problems end up making decisions
for us rather than um consulting us for
how the true structure of reality should
be.
Um there you know it's so interesting
every every conference I go to you see
one main topic that comes up and you
know the last conference that I went to
was knowledge graph conference in New
York and there Genai Gen AI was the hype
I mean it was just all about genai I
come here and I see a totally different
vibe which is you know it's going back
to grass uh grass level roots you know
or grassroots of graph itself, right?
Um, and I I you know, I I like this idea
of nodes, edges, and education. And I I
spent more time in most most of my time
in the edges group because I I thought,
you know, there were lots of new things
that I'd hadn't heard of before. And
like Dexter's talk, that was amazing.
That was really really good. And uh so
there are a few talks where
I hadn't thought about those things. And
I'm curious to see if that's where we're
moving towards, you know, um I mean next
year it'll be interesting to see where
where we are in terms of graphs. And uh
Katrina, hats off to you. This ontology
thing I though I didn't participate, it
was a lot of fun. I it's you know, you
you had people thinking in a very
different way and then that was a lot of
fun. So looking forward to this again.
Um well for me it's really easy because
I'm not coming from this world. So I
just feel I've been on such a learning
curve. Uh generally I was always so most
of my work is around trend analysis and
picking up so many trends from different
areas. I've always found it hard to use
kind of formal tools to deal with it uh
because they just seem to really
simplify things. So whether you know
you're just looking at regressions or
you're just looking at agent-based
modeling that kind of thing. So a lot of
my work was doing things in a more uh
qualitative and intuitive way. And I'm
actually really excited now to try and
and and use some of your tools and and
ontology to perhaps develop new products
around that. So yeah, lots to think
about.
>> With this uh we're at time like to